[Music]
zeki is selected from his college
to participate in an intercollegiate
personality competition
this screening round for this
competition is logical reasoning
zeki and his opponents have to solve a
puzzle given to them
in this screening round to enter the
competition
let's first look at the puzzle there are
10 bags of gold coins
each bag contains 10 gold coins
all the bags contain coins measuring 10
grams each
except for one bag which has all the
defective coins of
9 grams each the participants are
supposed to figure out the bag having
defective coins
to make their work easy they are
provided with a weighing machine
sounds like a piece of cake right nope
here comes the twist they can use this
weighing machine
only once moreover the coins look the
same
and the difference in the weight cannot
be made out very easily
just by physically holding them now the
task given to the participants
is to devise a strategy to find out the
bag which has the counterfeit
coins by using minimum possible bags
so what do you think will zeki crack the
puzzle and secure his place in this
competition
well he definitely does now let's look
at the strategy that zeki applied
which led him to the solution hey this
is ganesh here from don't memorize
before we get to the solution of this
riddle don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and hit the bell icon
so that you never miss a video from us
okay back to where we left off
since zeki knows that there's a strategy
here he decides not to think about 10
bags
and instead consider a small sample
he assumes that there are only three
bags
out of these two have 10 gold coins of
10 grams each
and one consists of counterfeit coins of
9 grams each
ok what next now he thinks
he can remove one coin from each bag and
check their weights
but then he realizes that he can use the
weighing machine only once
so he can only end up with the total
weight of three coins that is
29 grams but this wouldn't be of any
help
as he won't be able to make out which
coin weighs 9 grams
this gets him to the conclusion that the
equal number of coins from the bags
cannot be selected for weighing so he
thinks
what if he selects an unequal number of
coins from the three bags
since he has assumed three bags he
thinks he can remove
one coin from the first bag two from the
second and three coins from the third
bag
now if all the bags had 10 gram coins
then how much would the weighing machine
display
correct 60 grams that is because
there are in all six coins but seki
knows that this is not the case
there is one bag which has nine gram
coins
hence the total weight would definitely
be less than 60 grams
so zeki chalked out a table considering
the three possibilities
the first possibility being if bag one
has counterfeit coins
then we have this one coin of nine grams
from bag one
two coins of 10 grams from back two and
three coins again of 10 grams from back
three
now what's the total weight here yes
59 grams so he immediately writes down
the combinations of the other two cases
where the bags two or three may have the
defective coins
he is happily surprised to see that the
total weights in the three cases
are different thus depending upon the
total weight
he can easily say which bag has the
defective coins
and this is how zeki finds out his
strategy
that is if from bag one he removes n
number of coins
then from the bag two he will remove n
plus one number of coins
while from back three he will remove n
plus two coins
bingo zeki now has to apply this logic
to the puzzle given
he had earlier assumed to the puzzle
with three bags of gold coins
now he just has to apply this strategy
to the ten bags provided to him
so can you tell me how will zeki go
about it
that's right he will remove one gold
coin from bag one
that is n n plus one from back to
that is two n plus two from back three
that is three and so on up till back 10
from which we will remove 10 gold coins
so what would be the total number of
coins here yes
55 coins now if all the bags had 10 gram
coins
then the weighing machine would display
the weight as 550 grams
but zeki knows that it has to be less
than this
again he makes a table of all the ten
possibilities
like he did in the case of three bags
here is the table now all he has to do
is just weigh the coins and find it out
from the table
which bag has defective coins
but hold on the puzzle was to find the
bag with counterfeit coins by using
minimum possible bags
and in this strategy zeki would be using
all the ten bags
though the strategy is not wrong but he
needs to think of a one
which would be more efficient and would
guarantee his place in the competition
the only solution that he comes up with
is dividing the 10 bags in a particular
ratio
but the difficult part is how the bags
would be divided into sets
he needs to divide them in such a way
that even if one set of bags isn't
measured
he would still get the answer and to
obtain this
the only possible way he comes up with
is to divide the ten bags in the ratio
of
nine is to one and how would this
combination
assert in zeki the result let's check
zeki applies the previous strategy for
the first nine bags
now we can see here that from the nine
bags
he would draw 45 coins in all so if
these 9 bags have 10 gram coins
then what would be the total weight
right
450 grams but if the counterfeit coins
are in this set
then the scale would show less than 450
grams
and then depending on the reduction in
the weight zeki would know which bag has
the counterfeit coins
but what if the weighing machine
displays the weight as 450 grams
that is correct the count of feed coins
will be in bag 10
which wasn't included this way by using
nine bags
zeki would know which bag would have the
counterfeit coins
bingo now what if
zeki uses eight bags and keeps aside two
is it possible to obtain the result then
nope
then he will have to use the weighing
machine twice
why is that so that's because if zeki is
extremely unlucky
and these eight bags have 10 gram coins
then he would have to use the weighing
machine again
to figure out the faulty bag from these
two bags
so the only possible optimum solution is
where zeki divides the entire set into
the ratio
nine is to one or in general terms
we can say n minus one is to one
zeki applies this strategy and secures
his place in the competition
now before leaving let me shoot another
puzzle at you
but remember this one may or may not
follow the logic which we had used to
solve our puzzle
now nora also happens to participate in
the competition
and the puzzle given to her was this
suppose there are three bulbs in a
closed room and all
are switched off and there are three
switches outside the room
each bulb is operated by one of the
how do you figure out which switch
operates which bulb
if a person can go to the room only once
there are no windows and there is no
other way you can peep inside the room
for more such interesting puzzles do
subscribe to our channel
happy learning